>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
IT'S HARD TO REMEMBER NOW
BECAUSE HISTORY IS PRETTY HAZY
BUT IT WAS JUST THREE YEARS AGO
THAT JOE BIDEN WAS CONSIDERED
TOO DECREPIT, TOO CORRUPT, TO
OUT OF TOUCH EVER TO BECOME
PRESIDENT.
THAT WASN'T JUST THE VIEW FROM
THE RIGHT, BY THE WAY, THEY
MOSTLY STAYED OUT OF IT, THAT'S
WHAT FAITHFUL DEMOCRATS WERE
SAYING IN 2019, THREE SEPARATE
MEAL LIBERAL NEWS OUTLETS,
GUARDIAN, THE WEEK AND CNN ALL
PUBLISHED OP ADS WITH THE EXACT
SAME HEADLINES, WHY JOE BIDEN
SHOULDN'T RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
OTHER PUBLICATIONS MADE THE SAME
POINT WITH EQUAL VEHEMENCE.
I LIKE JOE BIDEN BUT HE
SHOULDN'T RUN FOR PRESIDENT SAID
A COLUMNIST ON USA TODAY.
BIDEN'S FAMILY AGREED WITH THIS.
THIS IS TRUE.
THEY DIDN'T WANT HIM TO BECOME
PRESIDENT EITHER.
SOME OF BIDEN'S CLOSEST
RELATIVES' ASSURED FRIENDS THAT
BIDEN WAS MERELY RUNNING TO WORK
OFF THE GRIEF FROM HIS SON'S
DEATH TWO YEARS AHEAD.
AND FOR MONTHS, IT SEEMED ALL
BUT ASSURED HE WOULDN'T WIN.
BIDEN'S FIRST DEBATE PERFORMANCE
IN JUNE WAS WRITTEN OFF AS A
DISASTER.
IT SEEMED OBVIOUS HE HAD NO
CHANCE OF A NOMINATION AND THEN
BERNIE SANDERS STARTED TO WIN
PRIMARIES.
FOR THE SECOND PRESIDENTIAL
CYCLE IN A ROW, SANDERS PROVED
TO BE THE ONLY DEMOCRAT IN THE
FIELD WITH LEGITIMATE GRASSROOTS
SUPPORT.
DONORS SAW THIS AND PANICKED.
THE GUY WHO HATES BILLIONAIRES,
WHAT'S HE GOING TO DO TO WALL
STREET?
SANDERS WAS UNACCEPTABLE TO THE
PEOPLE WHO FUND THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, BUT THERE WAS A PROBLEM.
WHAT WERE THE OPTIONS?
PETE BUTTIGIEG AND BETO
O'ROURKE?
NO.
BOTH TURNED OUT TO BE LIGHTER
THAN AIR.
ELIZABETH WARREN?
DOUBLE NO.
KAMALA HARRIS WAS HORRIBLE ON
EVERY LEVEL.
ABSOLUTELY NOBODY LIKED KAMALA
HARRIS AND FOR GOOD REASON.
SO IT TURNED OUT TO BE JOE BIDEN
BY DEFAULT.
GET OUT THE BIDEN SIGNS.
WE'RE ALL IN.
AND, OF COURSE, THE MEDIA GOT
THE MESSAGE IMMEDIATELY.
BY THE TIME HE WAS INAUGURATED,
HERE'S WHAT THE PRESS CORPS WAS
TELLING YOU ABOUT JOE BIDEN.
>> ANYBODY WHO HAS ANY
CONNECTION TO REALITY ABOUT WHAT
IS GOING ON AROUND THEM SHOULD
HAVE WATCHED THAT AND SAID THE
ADULTS ARE BACK IN THE ROOM.
>> IT SEEMS AS THOUGH WE HAVE A
PROFESSIONAL ADULT ONCE AGAIN IN
THE WHITE HOUSE WHO IS JUST
SIMPLY DOING THE WORK.
>> REALLY, THE THEME I WOULD SAY
IS THE ADULTS ARE BACK.
>> STILL, IT IS A RELIEF TO HAVE
ADULTS IN CHARGE.
>> NOW, WE HAVE ADULTS IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> OK, THE ADULTS ARE BACK IN
THE ROOM.
>> UM, THERE IS A SENSE I THINK
THE WORLD OVER THAT THE ADULTS
HAVE RETURNED.
>> WE HAVE AN ADULT IN THE WHITE
HOUSE NOW.
AND IT'S GLORIOUS.
>> Tucker:
[CHUCKLING]
THESE PEOPLE!
NEVER ORIGINAL THOUGHT AMONG
THEM.
HE'S AN ADULT.
IT'S GLORIOUS!
WELL, HALF TRUE.
BIDEN IS CERTAINLY AN ADULT.
HE'LL BE 80 THIS FALL.
BUT NO ONE IN WASHINGTON THINKS
THAT THE BIDEN PRESIDENCY IS
GLORIOUS ANYMORE.
THEY THINK IT'S A DISASTER, FULL
SHOW -- POLLS SHOW VOTERS
STRONGLY AGREE.
JOE BIDEN IS THE MOST UNPOPULAR
PERSON IN VIRTUALLY EVERY ROOM
HE ENTERS.
IF YOU DOUBT IT, WATCH THIS.
THIS WAS THE SCENE AT THE WHITE
HOUSE TODAY.
TAKE A CAREFUL LOOK AT THIS.
YOU'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
IT.
THAT'S THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IN HIS OWN HOUSE
SHUNNED.
NOBODY WOULD TALK TO HIM.
SO BIDEN WANDERED OFF LOOKING
VACANT AS THE CROWD FORMED
AROUND A FORMER PRESIDENT,
BARACK OBAMA, WHO WAS DEEPLY
GRATEFUL FOR THE ATTENTION.
THEN IT GOT WORSE IT GOT MUCH
MORE POIGNANT THAN THAT.
WATCH BIDEN TRY TO HORN IN ON
THE CONVERSATION SWIRLING AROUND
OBAMA.
EVERYONE INVOLVED IN THAT
CONVERSATION INCLUDING KAMALA
HARRIS WHO SUPPOSEDLY WORKS FOR
BIDEN IGNORED BIDEN COMPLETELY.
BIDEN TRIED TO GET BARACK'S
ATTENTION AND PUTS HIS HAND ON
HIS SHOULDER AND CALLS HIM
BARACK LIKE HE'S A FRIEND.
BARACK BLEW HIM OFF LIKE HE
WASN'T THERE.
ASK YOURSELF IF YOU'VE SEEN
ANYTHING SADDER IN YOUR LIFE
THAN THIS.
OH, MAKE IT
!
IT'S AWFUL!
NOW, IT'S TRUE THAT BARACK OBAMA
HAS NEVER LIKED JOE BIDEN FOR
THE EIGHT YEARS THEY WORKED
TOGETHER, OBAMA MOCKED HIM
RELENTLESSLY AS AN OLD WHITE
GUY.
HE KEPT BIDEN IN THE PERIPHERY,
THAT'S WHERE HE GOT THE UKRAINE
ACCOUNT.
EVEN AS SOMEONE AS ARROGANT AS
BARACK OBAMA COULD PRETEND IF HE
HAS TO PRETEND.
THAT'S THE POINT OF THE VIDEO WE
JUST SHOWED YOU.
OBAMA NO LONGER HAS TO PRETEND.
HE CAN TELL THE WORLD IN THE
CLEAREST POSSIBLE TERMS HE HAS
NO RESPECT FOR JOE BIDEN.
NOBODY AT THIS POINT HAS RESPECT
FOR JOE BIDEN.
HE'S INVITED HIS MOST -- EVEN
HIS MOST FAITHFUL SUPPORTERS IN
THE PRESS CORPS HAS FORGOTTEN
ABOUT HIM.
>> WAR ABROAD, ANXIETY AT HOME
AND INFLATION AT ITS HIGHEST
LEVEL IN 40 YEARS.
SKY-HIGH INFLATION IS ERASING
BIGGER PAYCHECKS WHILE HOURLY
EARNINGS ARE UP 5.6% OVER LAST
YEAR.
NEARLY 1 IN 5 WORKERS SAY
THEY'VE RUN OUT OF MONEY BEFORE
THEY GET THEIR NEXT CHECK.
>> YOU HAVE HISTORIC INFLATION.
YOU HAVE RECORD GAS PRICES.
AMERICANS ARE FEELING IT.
>> BIDEN'S NUMBERS HAVE DROPPED
BY DOUBLE-DIGITS WITH YOUNG
VOTERS AND THEY WERE A BIG PART
OF HIS COALITION IN 2020.
>> VOTER ANXIETY IS ABOUT MORE
THAN RISING PRICES OR RUSSIA'S
WAR IN UKRAINE.
>> VIOLENT CRIME IN AMERICAN
CITIES REMAINS PERSISTENTLY
HIGH.
THERE'S A GROWING PROBLEM AT THE
BORDER.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN'S APPROVAL
RATING STILL HASN'T FOUND BOTTOM
AND IT'S BEEN SLOWLY TRENDING
DOWN ALL YEAR.
>> Tucker: WAIT A SECOND!
CORRECTION!
BREAKING NEWS!
IT LOOKS LIKE INFLATION IS REAL!
NOT TRANSITORY.
IT'S ACTUALLY MAKING US POOR.
CRIME AND DISORDER IN THE CITIES
ARE REAL, TOO, AND GUESS WHAT?
IT LOOKS LIKE A TOTALLY
POINTLESS WAR WITH RUSSIA ISN'T
AS POPULAR AS WE THOUGHT IT WAS.
YOU'RE NOT A TRAITOR FOR NOT
WANTING IT.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, THEY'RE
ADMITTING ALL OF THAT.
FOR MONTHS, BIDEN'S BEEN TELLING
US EVERY BAD THING YOU NOTICE
AROUND YOU IS, OF COURSE,
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S FAULT AND THE
MEDIA HAVE BACKED HIM UP, BUT
SUDDENLY, THEY AREN'T BACKING
HIM UP ANYMORE.
READY TO BE SHOCKED AGAIN?
WATCH A GROUP OF LIBERAL TOADY'S
DEMOLISH THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE'S
FAVORITE TALKING POINT.
HERE IT IS.
>> EVERY TIME WE TALK ABOUT GAS
PRICES, PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
SAYING IT'S PUTIN'S PRICE HIKE.
THEY'RE TRYING TO INVASION THE
RUSSIAN -- TRYING TO BLAME THE
RUSSIAN PRESIDENT AND PUTIN FOR
THE GAS.
>> BIDEN HAS CALLED IT A PUTIN
PRICE HIKE BUT MOST AMERICANS
AREN'T BUYING IT.
>> WITH THE MIDTERMS NOW JUST A
FEW MONTHS AWAY AND INFLATION AT
A RECORD HIGH, THE PRESIDENT NOW
PUTTING THE BLAME SQUARELY ON
VLADIMIR PUTIN CALLING THIS A
PUTIN PRICE HIKE.
GAS PRICES WERE ALREADY RISING
BEFORE RUSSIA STARTED THIS WAR.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE IS TRYING TO
DO -- TO DO BOTH, BLAME PUTIN,
BLAME THE OIL AND GAS COMPANIES,
BUT AMERICANS JUST DON'T AGREE.
>> Tucker:
[CHUCKLING]
WHAT?
NOW THEY SELL US -- IS YOUR HEAD
SPINNING YET?
YEAH.
OK, JUST ONE MORE.
HERE IS SANDY CORTEZ WHO HAS
FINALLY TURNED ON JOE BIDEN.
NOW, IT WAS JUST A YEAR AND A
HALF AGO THAT SANDY'S JOB WAS TO
USE ALL THE STREET CRED SHE
EARNED GROWING UP IN THE LEAFY
SUBURBS OF WESTCHESTER AND
HEADING OVER TO BOSTON
UNIVERSITY, USE ALL OF THAT
"URBAN CREDIBILITY" TO CONVINCE
THE "YOUNG PEOPLE" THAT ACTUALLY
JOE BIDEN IS OK.
ACTUALLY, HE'S OLD AND WHITE,
BUT GO AHEAD AND VOTE FOR HIM
ANY WAY HE'S GOT SANDY'S HEEL OF
APPROVAL.
SELLING JOE BIDEN IS HER JOB.
SHE DID IT.
BUT NOT ANYMORE.
SANDY CORTEZ SEES CHANGE COMING.
IF THERE'S ONE THING SHE'S GOOD
AT IS KNOWING THE PREVAILING
WIND.
SHE'S HAPPY TO ATTACK BIDEN.
WATCH THIS.
>> WE NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT MIDDLE THE
OF THE ROAD AND INCREASINGLY
NARROW BAND OF INDEPENDENT
VOTERS.
THIS IS REALLY ABOUT THE
COLLAPSE AND SUPPORT AMONG YOUNG
PEOPLE, AMONG THE DEMOCRATIC
BASE FEELING THEY'VE WORKED
OVERTIME TO GET THIS PRESIDENT
ELECTED AND THEY HAVEN'T --
AREN'T NECESSARILY BEING SEEN.
>> Tucker: OH, SANDY IS OUT SO
EVERYONE IS OUT.
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE?
EXACTLY WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND ITS
MEDIA WING HAVE DECIDED TO
JETSON JOE BIDEN.
THERE WAS NEVER AN OFFICIAL
ORDER TO DO THIS.
WHAT YOU'RE WATCHING HERE AS
ALWAYS IS THE HIVE MIND AT WORK.
DEMOCRATS HAVE THE SAME
REACTIONS BECAUSE THEY HAVE THE
SAME INDIFFERENT.
BIDEN IS -- INSTINCTS.
BIDEN WEAK.
WE MUST GET RID OF HIM.
THE FIRST RULE OF DOG PACKS, FOR
EXAMPLE F A SINGLE DOG WAIVERS
OR LAGS BEHIND, THE OTHER DOGS
WILL KILL HIM, EVEN IF THEY'RE
FROM THE SAME LITTER.
YES.
IT'S NOTHING PERSONAL, JUST A
MATTER OF GROUP SURVIVAL.
THAT'S EXACTLY HOW THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY OPERATES.
INDIVIDUALS ARE IRRELEVANT TO
THE PARTY.
THE GROUP IS ALL THAT MATTERS.
NO ONE AT THE DNC ACTUALLY CARES
ABOUT JOE BIDEN OR EVER HAS OR
FOR THAT MATTER CARES ABOUT
GEORGE FLOYD OR DAVID HOGG OR
ANYONE ELSE THEY TELL YOU IS AN
EITHER REPLACEABLE HERO.
ALL -- IRREPLACEABLE HERO.
ALL PEOPLE ARE EXTENDIBLE.
WHAT MATTERS IS THE PARTY AND
THE PARTY MATTERS BECAUSE IN
NUMBERS THERE IS POWER ON SOME
LEVEL, JOE BIDEN KNOWS THIS HE
SPENT HIS LIFE IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
HE NEVER WORKED OUTSIDE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, SO HE
UNDERSTANDS HOW THIS ENDS.
INEVITABLY AFTER 50 YEARS, IT'S
HIS TURN TO BE ELIMINATED.
WILL HE SCREAM FOR MERCY OR TAKE
IT LIKE A MAN?
THAT'S THE ONLY QUESTION.
BIDEN CAN'T LEAD.
THEREFORE AT SOME POINT SOON, HE
WON'T BE ALLOWED TO LEAD.
IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
AND IF YOU DOUBT IT, WATCH BIDEN
TALK SOMETIME.
HERE IS BIDEN THE OTHER DAY
TELLING US JILL BEHIND WAS IN
FACT ONCE BARACK OBAMA'S VICE
PRESIDENT.
>> AND I'M DEEPLY PROUD OF THE
WORK SHE'S DOING AS FIRST LADY
WITH JOINING FORCES INITIATIVE.
SHE STARTED WITH MICHELLE OBAMA
WHEN SHE WAS VICE PRESIDENT AND
NOW CARRIES ON.
>> Tucker: YOU KNOW?
IT PAINS ME TO PLAY THAT.
IT'S NOT A UNIQUE EXAMPLE.
WE SEE EXAMPLES OF THAT EVERY
SINGLE DAY AND HIS FELLOW
DEMOCRATS SEE THAT, TOO.
SO THEY'VE DECIDED TO REPLACE
JOE BIDEN, PERIOD.
BUT HOW WILL THEY DO I